I've talked to girls that have slept
with like 50 to 100 guys and they'll
open late and if they say they only
loved roughly five like out of a hundred
dudes there's only and that's what I
realized I'm like I think women have
roughly like five chances at love
because like they did all this sex right
but they couldn't fall in love after
five times yeah and there's the studies
to prove that when you look at things
like pair blending I know yeah there's a
bit of controversy around those studies
when I look at the patterns in the data
it makes sense to me especially given
you know the psychology of females as
well especially with relationship to
Children it would make sense that you
are supposed to kind of latch onto the
one person as a female at least